[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So today we are
so lucky to have Andrea
Nguyen of "The Pho Cookbook."
Please join me in
welcoming her to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
And with that,
please take it away.
ANDREA NGUYEN: All right.
Thank you so much.
We've got a few
extra seats around
if anybody wants to sit down and
maybe get a better view of what
I'm going to be working on.
SPEAKER: And feel
free to move stools.
Make yourself at home.
ANDREA NGUYEN: This is
your kitchen space today.
And like with a lot of
classes in teaching--
I'm a professional cookbook
author and cooking teacher
and consultant.
And so a lot of what
I do is help people
become better home
cooks, because I
am a professional home cook.
I'm not a restaurant chef.
So I'm always
thinking of how can I
help home cooks figure
out ways to make foods
that they may or may not be
familiar with, and really
up their game?
So "The Pho Cookbook"
is my fifth cookbook.
And I'm Vietnamese by heritage.
I was born in Vietnam.
And when my family
fled Vietnam in 1975,
we brought a lot of
our food memories
with us, because for
a family of seven,
we only had two
little suitcases.
So imagine carrying
like two backpacks
worth of your belongings
and going to another country
to start over.
And so what did we have but the
flavors that my parents wanted
to recreate.
And they were people in
their forties with five kids.
And so, you know, we weren't
living near a Pho shop.
We couldn't walk out and
get Pho like we used to.
So they ended up making a
lot of the food at home.
And initially we
had to cook a lot
from an American supermarket,
which back in 1979--
and some of you may be
old enough to remember--
it was really sad.
Soy sauce, bad rice,
yucky vegetables.
A lot of that has changed.
And with "The Pho Cookbook,"
because a lot of people
sense it's like, oh!
I can't make pho.
I've had people tell
me that it takes hours!
I've even had Vietnamese
people tell me
that their parents
tell them, oh my God!
It takes like an
overnight simmer.
And pho shop owners will say,
I brewed this pho for 18 hours.
Well, when you're making pho at
home for as few as two people
or up to eight people,
you can really, really
spend a lot less time, because
you're small batching it.
You're making
artisanal pho at home.
So you don't have to
spend that much time.
So when you work your
way through the book,
you'll notice that
at the front part
there is this thing
called a pho manual.
And it explains like 99% of
what I know about making pho.
And the extra 1% is very
boring and distracting.
So I left that out.
For example, like
one man told me
he had to scrape the bones
off until his knuckles bled
or something.
And I was like, I'm not
putting that in the book.
I was just like, he said
it's a waste of time.
And I thought, well, yeah.
I think so.
And then after the
pho manual, there's
a chapter called master pho.
And what it offers are
different ways to make pho.
So you can spend as
little as 40 minutes
doctoring up canned broth.
So if you could do me a favor
and hand me that can of broth--
this is audience
participation time.
And I'm not doing any
product placement.
But stuff like this--
Swanson's chicken broth.
Or if you're shopping at
Whole Foods, then by all
means the Whole Foods
365 broth is really good.
You want sort of a
higher sodium broth.
And so there are three
different recipes.
40 minutes, with grocery stores
ingredients like this, and then
with like Annie Chun noodles--
if you're shopping at a regular
market, it's very good--
you can have pho.
Chicken, vegetable, or beef.
There is another
method of making pho
using a pressure cooker.
How many of you own
pressure cookers?
The instant pot.
How many are you
instant potters?
So you can spend like
an hour and a half,
if you're using an
instant pot, please reduce
the amount of water by one cup.
OK?
Just saying that,
because the instant pot
has this maximum fill
line, as you know.
And you can go up to that point.
And it also retains pressure
for a very, very long time.
So you can kind of save
yourself a little time.
And it's not venting.
So you should get
the same quantity
with one cup less water.
Just saying.
If you're using something like
a pressure cooker to make pho,
you can do it in an hour and
a half from beginning to end.
And you can also then
freeze your broth.
And there are
instructions on how
to do that so that you could
have what I call the pho
bank at your disposal.
My mother now lives
off my frozen pho bank.
She's 82.
She gets to rest.
But anyway.
And then the last
method of making pho
is with an old school simmer.
That's where you have--
it's a weekend project.
OK.
Pressure cooker pho,
that's a weeknight project.
You can make weekend
pho on a weeknight.
Doctoring up quick pho
from using canned broth.
That could be like a lunchtime
thing, or a weeknight thing.
But when you have time,
brew from scratch.
And what we're going to
have serving you here today
is a vegan beef version of pho.
But I also wanted to talk
about making classic beef pho
old school using a stockpot.
So we're talking then like four
or five hours worth of time.
But most of it's passive.
You can text.
You can work.
You can take your dog on a walk.
Whatever.
And one of the first
things that you
want to start doing
when you're making pho--
and regardless of
different kinds.
And what I'm going
to talk about applies
to pho across the board.
The aromatics.
Basically we're talking
onion and ginger.
Get yourself some plump ginger.
And in my recipes
I'll say chubby.
Chubby, you know, like the
size of your big toe chubby.
And I think we all get a
sense of what that means.
If you're using a scale--
and a scale unfortunately
never lies--
one inch of ginger is
approximately one ounce.
So you'll find
sometimes like, whoa,
that ginger looks like
it's really chubby.
But because it's
got like maybe--
it's just really
dense or too watery.
But you really get
up to that one ounce
for that gingery quality.
And then you want
to get that going.
Traditionally we would
put that on a brazier.
You can use onion, yellow onion.
Or you can also use a shallot.
So in Vietnam, you and I
would be squatting next
to a charcoal brazier, because
we don't have indoor grills.
We don't have ovens that we
could use a broiler element.
We don't have gas
stoves, a lot of us.
But we do have grills.
You can use an indoor grill.
At home I have a gas range.
So I'm just going to put
it directly on the grill.
So this business about
charring the aromatics.
What is it?
I think it is the
only aspect of pho
that the Vietnamese really
borrowed from the French
in terms of culinary technique.
There's a lot of
discussion about oh, pho
comes from France because it
sounds like a French word, pho.
Like pot-au-feu, like fire.
Well, the French
were in Vietnam when
pho developed, which was in the
early part of the 20th century.
So we're talking in
late 1800s, early 1900s
in the northern part of Vietnam.
So Vietnam is this
very long country.
Hanoi's up here.
And this is where all the
pho action was happening.
And the French were around.
And they like their beef.
So they were slaughtering
a lot of cows.
And they left the scraps--
things like bones.
OK.
So these are like bones.
I'm going to-- it's
coming from here.
OK.
Sometimes they're
called femur bones.
So marrow bones.
I'm just going to pass these
around so that you get a sense.
A lot of times like
with cookbooks,
they don't explain what
things look like to you.
And they're like, oh, just
go out and get a femur bone.
And you're like, what
does that look like?
That is a marrow
bone or a femur bone.
And if it happens to
include the socket,
that's called a knuckle bone.
So just remember our biology
classes, our skeletons
and stuff.
And I'm going to talk while
I'm doing some of this stuff.
The other thing is sometimes
there are neck bones.
So if someone can
pass that along there.
I have my certain range, you
guys, that I get to move into.
But like I-- yes, please.
Google makes pho and
cooks other things
with these amazing,
amazing bones.
So as a home cook, you are not
going to be accessing bones
like this.
And please, cutting
them is not something
you want to try at home.
It requires a saw like a
butcher saw, like a band saw.
And at markets
like Asian markets,
you'll see that
they're running them
through the saws like this.
But this is like an entire
cervical spine of the cow.
And so you can
blend bones-- marrow
bones, knuckle
bones, neck bones.
Neck bones contribute
meaty flavor.
Marrow bones contribute fat.
Knuckle bones contribute
sort of like some tendons.
For all of you who like tendon,
you can just scrape the tendon
off the knuckle bones.
Who needs to go buy tendon?
That's what a pho shop does.
You're not opening a pho shop.
If you were, you wouldn't
be working at Google.
So.
SPEAKER: I don't know.
Some entrepreneurial
Googlers out there.
It's not a conflict of interest.
ANDREA NGUYEN: No.
No.
But you've got pho shops
going on here on the campus.
There are a lot of
impurities in these bones
that you're dealing with.
So oftentimes when I'm
making pho at home,
I've got my aromatics
going on one burner.
And at the same
time, I do this thing
where I parboil the bones.
So what happens is I blanch--
parboiling means you're
putting something in water.
And then you're bringing
it up to a boil.
And then you're going
to turn off the heat.
What does that do?
That is called scum.
It is not going to do anything
to contribute to your broth
but to dirty it up.
No bueno.
We do not-- think of this
like the scuzzy stuff
that you see in the ocean.
And you're like, I do not
want to wade into that.
This is not what you
want in your broth.
And when you do this, I have
to operate an induction burner
while I'm talking.
SPEAKER: It's a trick.
That whole thing.
I can never get it to work.
It's not just you.
ANDREA NGUYEN: So typically,
I'll bring this to a boil,
let it go for a little bit.
And then I will take
it over to the sink
and then just dump it out.
And what this allows
me to do is very,
very easily remove any kind of
scuzziness that would otherwise
really cloud up my broth.
And you would be
using a lot more bones
than what I have here.
But I wanted you to see
that once that you do this,
you brew your broth, and
number one, the flavor
is not going to be off
because of the bones.
There.
You can pass it around
if you guys can see
what blanched bones looks like.
But it's a lot cleaner.
And same thing with chicken.
Just parboil them, dump
it out, spray it down.
This is what that sprayer is
really good for in your sink.
They don't tell you that
when you buy your house
or buy a new
kitchen faucet sink.
But that's what you're doing.
And yes.
AUDIENCE: How long do
you parboil them for?
ANDREA NGUYEN: Two
to three minutes.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
ANDREA NGUYEN: Yeah.
I did it less because
these bones, were just
like two of them.
And I had them sitting around.
But parboiling, once
you strain the broth,
man, it is really
lovely and clear.
So with aromatics, so
you're going to let
them go until they
start blackening.
And you're through with
the blackening when
you're looking about like this.
It's a little CSI-looking.
Right?
But you're looking
to char the outside.
You're not looking to cook
the entire thing, because you
want some of that rawness.
All this charring
does is convert
some of the harsher
qualities of the onion
and the ginger or the
shallot to a sweet level.
And that imparts this beautiful
sweetness to the broth.
So take your time to do that
when you're doing old school.
If you're pressure cooking
it, what I found, my friends,
is that it does not matter.
Skip the charring.
Because the pressure
cooker, it's
like the Beavis and
Butt-head of appliances,
because it's literally
cooking under pressure.
It's got this gasket that
goes on really, really
tight on the top.
And it's like, uh!
Like this.
There is nowhere for
that steam to escape.
Whereas in a regular
pot, we can go ahead
and let the steam escape.
Whether the lid's on or not,
there is steam escaping.
But in a pressure cooker,
that steam's going nowhere.
So it moves really fast
and it moves really hot.
So it's expressing
flavors a lot more rapidly
and with more force.
As a result, it wipes
out all the nuances
that you would
get in doing this.
So there's a
technique that I have
in preparing the pressure cooker
pho where you get to skip this.
Just so that you know,
so that you don't always
have to do the same methods.
There are different
work-arounds.
And so once that you
get the aromatics
to this level, what
you're going to do
is you're going to peel it.
And I oftentimes give it
a little rinse under water
to soften the skin.
I'm just gonna turn that off.
And then you can use a peeler.
Or you can use a knife.
But you want to get all
of that brownness off.
And let's see if I can
use one of these guys.
Yeah.
Look at that.
You want to get that
stuff off of there.
And if you're standing
over your sink,
it's really smart to do this
while you're over your sink.
Then you can just let the
stuff drop right in there.
But you want to get
all of the charred bits
off, because that
will impart color.
Is that what you were saying?
AUDIENCE: I said,
it smells good.
ANDREA NGUYEN: Oh,
You're like, it
smells really good.
And I'm hungry.
I wish she would just hasten up.
Pho is all about
patience, my dear.
No, it is.
And you know, I'm
going to tell you.
I've been making
and eating pho--
well, I've been eating
pho since I was 5 and 1/2.
But I've been making pho
probably for about 12 years
since I started
writing my first book.
And I was like, you
know, if I'm going
to be a respectable
Vietnamese cook,
I need to learn how to make pho.
And then I realized
that it just took
practice and a lot of eating.
And there's also travel too,
because everywhere I go,
I try to find a pho
shop to stop by.
And there's a lot of stories
about pho that are really cool.
So like I talked to
this guy who talked
about his scraping the bones.
And he was a man in Hanoi
who was like a former cop.
And he's like, I think I
want to open a pho shop.
And so he went and he
apprenticed for months
with this master pho vendor.
And then at the end
of the line he's
like, it's really a lot of work.
I don't think I want to do this.
But he learned the thing about
the bone-scraping business.
Anyway.
So you get your
onion to this level.
And then what you want to
do is cut it into chunks.
And then you want to
just give it a smack.
If you have a meat
mallet, otherwise
known as a meat tenderizer,
that thing that's
like a hammer for the kitchen?
Use that on this.
It's OK.
Because otherwise sometimes
when I use a knife,
it kind of goes flying.
And what I'm going to
do is-- like that--
is I'm going to pass this around
so that you guys can smell it.
Here you go.
So there's a certain
sweetness, sweet spiciness.
And that's what
imparts flavor to pho.
Now let's talk about the spices.
And you would do the same
thing with the onion.
And if you're working
with shallot, then by all
means they're smaller.
This is what I would
call a small shallot.
In Vietnam, the shallots
are about this small.
They're tiny.
And they look like
red boiling onions.
In America where everything's
bigger, buy bigger shallots.
In fact, in the recipes, you'll
see me say, by huge ones.
Because then it'll
take less time.
And it imparts a flavor that's
a little bit stronger than onion
is.
Onion's a little bit sweeter.
And so Vietnamese cooks like
my mother came to America
and found that their beloved
shallot now cost a lot more.
This is like the typical
onion in Vietnam.
Yellow onions are
very expensive.
But over here in the States,
yellow onion is affordable.
And shallot is expensive.
So people did a switcheroo.
This is a little sweeter.
This is a little
bit more pungent.
So the flavors of American pho--
what we're all pretty much more
used to--
is really based upon this
hyphenated experience.
And so the pho story is one
that we can plug into at many,
many different levels
is what I'm saying.
And just because
you're Vietnamese
does not mean that you need
to know how to make pho
or that you're going
to make it well.
All it takes is
practice and a lot
of just figuring out like
teasing out what goes into pho.
So first we got the aromatics.
Then you've got your
beef bones there.
Or if you're making a vegetarian
one, you've got vegetables.
And in this beautiful bowl
are all of the vegetables
that we used for the vegan pho
broth that you'll be tasting.
There's also a beef pho
one that you'll be tasting.
But the only thing that may
actually be interesting to you
is what the hell is an
apple doing in here?
The apple is in the broth.
And you'll see in the
recipes, because I needed
a little natural sweetness.
So Vietnamese food, like
a lot of Asian food,
is a balance of savory sweet.
So naturally, hey, I'm going
to use a little MSG, right?
Sort of like mother's
little helper.
But a lot of us don't
want to use MSG.
Or maybe it's not like a
regular American kitchen item.
But you need that
little sweetness.
And so traditionally
you would get that
from using this stuff, which
is Chinese yellow rock sugar.
And it's available
at Asian markets.
And they look like a gemstone
that you can maybe make
a ring out of for your partner.
Or sometimes they're
like these big chunks.
But this is the packaging
that it comes in.
And get the yellow stuff,
not the white stuff.
Because the yellow stuff--
it has a little
better rounder flavor.
It's a semi-refined
sugar, if you're
interested in glycemic issues.
But do you need that?
Not necessarily.
If you use a Fuji
apple, then you
get that natural
sweetness built in.
And you don't really need
to go and get that sugar.
The sugar is very
easy to use, just
like MSG is very easy to use
for that little bit of burst.
And they're different
levels of sweetness.
But I found that when you're
not near an Asian market,
or you don't want to
go, the little apple
is quite, quite nice.
Make sure you peel
it before you use it,
because there are waxes
and stuff in there.
So you've got your main
featured ingredients.
Let's talk about the spices.
So typically people are like
oh, pho is all about star anise.
No.
That is not the
only spice in pho.
It's a blend.
It's a dance of spice notes.
And the spices should never
ever hit you on the head.
What happens is a
lot of pho cooks--
professional and
home cooks-- they
will add the spices toward
the end of the brewing time.
And sometimes they
kind of go overboard.
And it's like, boom!
Way too much spice.
And you're not
getting the subtleties
of pho, which is the
beefiness, or the vegetables,
or the chicken, or
even sometimes seafood.
So at home you can put those
spices right into your broth
as you're making it.
And they will then
kind of get subsumed
into the layers of flavors
that you're building.
And so what have we got?
Yes we've got our stick star
anise friends right here.
We've also got coriander seed.
In my chicken pho broth, when
I'm starting from raw chicken,
I use coriander seed, a few
cloves, and also cilantro.
Chicken, for obvious reasons, is
a different animal than a cow.
And the flesh is lighter.
So it really cannot
take star anise unless
the chicken's been-- like you'll
see in the rotisserie chicken
pho recipe I use star
anise and cinnamon,
because that's where you
can really like take it.
Because a roast
chicken or a roast
turkey has a strong flavor.
Whereas when you're
using raw chicken,
it's much more delicate.
And you should treat your
proteins appropriately.
And that thing about
chicken not being a cow,
that came from my mother.
Because one day I was like, Mom.
You know, like everybody's
making their chicken pho
with star anise and cinnamon.
She looked at me.
She goes, they're
different animals.
It is so true.
She's like in her eighties.
She gets to say what
she wants to say.
So we've got coriander
seed, star anise.
And when you use star
anise, everybody, make sure
you count the number
of pods, like I say.
Big whole nice lovely pods.
And if they're broken, it's OK.
But if they've got
little ones, then that
doesn't really count as a pod.
So count them up,
cause you don't always
get whole star anise.
Whole cloves.
In Vietnamese we call this,
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE],
which means "fragrant nail."
It looks like a nail.
It's very strong.
So I just add just
a few of them.
And use the whole ones.
Get nice plump ones.
These are all spices that you
can find at a regular market
in a bulk foods spice section,
for example at a health food
store, so that you don't
have to commit to buying
entire packages of them.
There's also cinnamon sticks.
So these are just
regular cinnamon sticks.
And oftentimes, the
cinnamon that we're
buying in our
regular supermarkets
is coming from Vietnam.
Bonus!
Who would have known?
So pass those along.
And cinnamon comes
in different sizes.
Sometimes they're slender.
Sometimes they're medium.
Sometimes they're husky.
And the amount that
you use will vary
on how much pho you're making.
So you'll see that in the
recipe-- slender, medium,
or husky.
And there's a weight amount in
the pho manual that you'll see.
Also fennel.
Fennel is very
sweet and aromatic.
So that contributes
to pho sometimes too.
The last thing I
want to talk about
is an unusual pho spice that
you don't see that often
in the United States.
And it's this stuff.
This is Chinese black cardamom.
And it looks like a nutmeg,
for those of you who
are familiar with whole spices.
And you buy it whole
at Chinese markets.
Indian cooking also relies
upon Chinese black cardamom.
And theirs are smaller.
So if you're shopping
at an Indian market,
and you're buying
Indian cardamom,
use a weight amount for your
broth so that you're spot on.
Because otherwise they are a
lot smaller than you think.
And of course, I got
it to work, Didi.
So this, they come
in different sizes.
And you're gonna see there's
like small, medium, and large.
So what does it
look like inside?
There are these little
pyramid-shaped pods.
It's very mentholly.
I've shown a lot of chefs and
even bartenders black cardamom.
And some bartenders
are like, oh, I'm
going to shave it into my
cocktail, which then gave me
this other idea, which is
to make a pho spice blend.
So for you to get an association
of what all the spices are
like together, so I've
brought a couple of samples.
And the smaller one is
made with star anise.
And in the taller one
it says pho cardamom.
So this one has a little star
anise and some black cardamom.
And so they're different.
So in the book, I
use this in dishes
where I want to turn
something a little pho-ish.
So fried rice.
I want that hit.
Boom!
Goes into the fried
rice as I'm cooking.
How do I make a pho dumpling?
Put a little pho spice in
there to give it that lift.
And I make a from-scratch
hoisin sauce.
So hoisin sauce typically
uses Chinese five spice.
And the hoisin sauce that is
served oftentimes at pho shops
is really sweet and kind
of yucky, in my opinion.
I'm just saying.
You may love it.
But it can have a much more
sophisticated complexity
if you make it
yourself out of miso.
So I'm going to throw some
of pho spice in there.
I also use it in a cocktail--
a pho michelada beer cocktail.
I rim the glass
with kosher salt.
You're like, I want one now!
And so this is a great
thing to have around.
And you can keep it in
your cupboard for a while.
If you like it, you can
double it or triple it,
whatever you like.
And it's just a really
nice little thing
to play around with.
You can mix it with kosher
salt and create your own rub
for pork.
I also use it to make meatballs.
You know those snappy
little meatballs.
You can make those meatballs
out of grocery store ingredients
and a food processor.
And it's no longer mystery meat.
It's really something
that you prepared.
And so there's a lot
going on with pho
that we don't know about.
So foundation stuff.
Let's talk about how to
put a bowl of pho together.
The other thing that I want
to discuss before that is-- so
your broth is done.
You want to strain it.
So I am all into
straining through muslin.
It is much more ecological
than using paper towel
or cheesecloth, which
oftentimes you cannot recycle.
This little guy, I
have used it for--
I don't know-- two
or three years.
I have different ones.
You buy the fabric
at a fabric store.
It's unbleached muslin.
And I go home and I tear it into
pieces around 18 by 18 square.
And I launder it in
the washing machine.
And the edges fray
really beautifully.
It traps all the impurities
and just enough fat
so that you still have
some fat in the broth.
Cause guess what?
Fat is flavor.
Oftentimes pho broth is
totally devoid of fat
and it's kind of thin.
But you need the
fat for roundness.
And so the muslin does that.
Right afterwards you can launder
it with regular dish soap,
hang it out to dry or
throw it in the wash.
And you're good.
I use that to make soy milk.
Cause I make my own soy milk
sometimes to make fresh tofu.
But I've got to ring out water
from tofu when I'm crushing it.
Goes in there.
Vegetables.
Like sometimes if you're
pickling something
or you're making an Asian
salad with cucumber--
stuff that has a lot of water--
wring it out that way.
Don't use your hands.
I mean, it's almost
kind of like,
just let the muslin
kind of do its thing.
And you can reuse it.
My problem with cheesecloth
is that it oftentimes bulks
and expands and rips.
And then you can't
re-use it so well.
So strain through muslin.
With ingredients like bones
and stuff, you can go ahead
and you can bulk up your bones
by saving bones from other food
cooking projects.
You know?
And so you can amend
your collection.
And one last thing
about the beef pho.
People often ask what is the
best cut for beef pho in terms
of the cooked beef?
Go brisket.
And that's a beautiful
chunk right there.
And I'm going to ask you to do
a little extra heavy lifting
for me and hand me the brisket.
So this is what you would
see at a butcher shop.
And I like to get the brisket
from the fattier part,
because it's just going
to have more flavor.
So when you're shopping,
ask the butcher,
can I get the thicker chunk
with a little bit of fat on it?
Because that's
going to add flavor.
And there's very little going
on with pho in terms of--
it's a boiling thing.
That's why in the book I'm
like, if you can boil water,
you can make pho.
Because that's about as
technical as it gets.
But there are certain things
about the ingredients,
like, you want to choose
your ingredients wisely.
Buy the best bones and the
best brisket, meats and noodles
and stuff that you can afford.
And then your pho will
taste even better.
And then so that's going on.
So your broth is taking care.
It's strained.
And when you're
making your broth,
the only salty element
that you have going on
is salt. You're going to season
the broth at the end with fish
sauce or soy sauce, or I
use Bragg liquid aminos,
which is a really
umami-intense ingredient.
And you do that at the end,
because you want that umami
burst to happen at the end.
That expression of I'm
savory to happen then.
I used to put it
in the broth when
I was simmering everything.
And I got some flack for it.
So I did that 10 years ago.
And then when I was researching
pho in Hanoi for a "Saveur"
magazine article
back in 2010, there
were these two chefs who
were in their sixties.
And they said, sister.
We have your cookbook.
And I was like, oh, great.
That's not a good
beginning, right?
And they were talking about
"Into the Vietnamese Kitchen."
They said, you know that
pho recipe of yours?
Why do you put your fish
sauce at the beginning and not
the end?
And I was like, because
that's how I like it.
And I like how it
flavors the meat.
So they go, no, no, no.
Put it at the end.
You're going to get
the floral qualities
of fish sauce that way.
So I went home.
And I was talking to my mom.
She goes, oh, yeah.
I've been wondering for
years why you do that.
[LAUGHTER]
So then I tried it out.
And you do.
You get that expression
of savoriness.
And you get the role of those
umami ingredients as a burst
rather than as a layer.
Because pho otherwise
when you taste the broth,
you're going, hm.
It needs a little something.
But then once you
finish it-- it's
like a finishing salt function.
OK?
So think of it that way.
And so you're going
to season your broth.
Always season your broth
a little bit saltier
than what you're
comfortable with,
because the rest of the
ingredients are not that salty.
We're talking about
noodles that have just
been-- these are fresh
noodles that Google uses.
When you're using dried noodles
like the ones in the box,
or these up here--
sorry.
You didn't know
sitting there was going
to be so problematic today.
But I do not have
Wilt Chamberlain arms.
So he's a basketball player
from a very long time ago.
So noodles come in
different widths.
OK.
So small, medium, large.
Like clothing sizes,
there is no standard.
So you just have to look.
So think of it as
linguini is small.
Fettuccini is medium, or what
you would use for Pad Thai.
Pappardelle is large.
For pho soup--
and you would want
to use like small or medium.
The medium width noodles
give you a little bit more
of a mouth feel to them.
And some people
really like that.
In Vietnam, the difference
between northern and southern
pho is oftentimes the
width of the noodles,
as well as the
flavor of the broth.
So they're wider in the North.
And the broth is salty, sweet.
In the South, the
noodles are narrower.
And the flavor is sweet, salty.
That's part of the regional pho
fight that goes on in Vietnam.
So these are brands
that I really like.
And I picked these
up at Asian markets.
So we're talking about
Ranch 99, Lion, Marina.
If you're traveling to
other parts of the country,
you can also pick H Mart, which
is a really well-known chain.
So any time that you have--
sometimes there's a little
bit of scuzz left over
in your broth.
This little guy, which is an
Asian scum skimmer or soup
skimmer, is great for--
it's very, very silky.
And before I get
this dirty, I'm just
going to pass it around so
that you get to feel it.
It is very smooth.
And it gets that scum right off.
And it is just a
fabulous tool to get.
You can order those online.
I believe those are
called soup scummers.
But like my friends and I were
like, get the scum skimmer!
And it's really a
wonderful, wonderful tool
for removing
impurities from broth.
So you've got your noodles.
And if you're using dry
noodles, what you need to do
is to soak them first.
You rehydrate them
in hot tap water.
So let them sit in there
until they're opaque and soft.
And then the beauty
of doing that is
that once they're
rehydrated, and drained,
you can keep them in your
fridge for five days.
Hello!
Pho any time.
Right?
Some people boil their
noodles before they plate them
up and make their bowls.
The problem with that is that
you can't have leftovers,
because cooked rice noodles,
they break under refrigeration.
So if you soak them, then
you're good to go for five days
whenever you want pho.
The other things that
you can perhaps--
so you've got your
protein setup.
So you've got your meats ready.
You've got your-- thank you.
If you're a vegetarian,
then we have tofu.
And you can go ahead and
you can slice everything up.
You've got the onion.
This is very, very
thinly sliced red onion.
You can use yellow
onion, if you like.
You've got cilantro.
And if you prep your
cilantro ahead of time,
you can wash it, spin
it dry, chop it up.
You can keep it in the
fridge for a day in advance.
Green onions.
Use the green part with
the solid white part.
Some people, traditionally
they would add this
to the simmering pho broth
for a little special treat.
It turns kind of leek-like.
So you could drop that
into your pho broth
as you are getting things ready.
The reason why you don't
want to use that stuff raw--
unless you've got these slender,
slender spring onions, like,
we're talking the size of
a wooden pencil slender--
is that it's very harsh.
So not good for a date night.
Date night pho, not good.
So you want to use
just the green part,
and just very thinly slice it.
And you can do this
prep for the garnish.
Like I said, a day or
so in advance, or just
while you're
gathering everything.
Phos are great team projects.
You've got friends,
you have family over,
set up a pho assembly line.
Get them all to put
their own bowls together.
And you just taste the
broth and ladle it over.
And they can choose
their proteins.
And then you've got your
tofu or chicken or--
the thing when you're working
with the toppings for pho
for the protein
elements, they to be thin
enough so that they can be
warmed up by the hot broth
very quickly.
The other thing too is that you
need it to be chopstickable.
You can pick it up
with a chopstick.
So I would not say put a chunk
like this into my bowl of pho.
No!
Right?
Clearly for the
fact that how can I
eat this with my chopsticks?
Well, you don't have to eat
pho with your chopsticks.
You can use a fork if
you like with a spoon.
But the thing is that
it's just unpleasant.
And the hot broth is what's
going to warm things up.
And it's not going to warm
up a block of tofu like this.
It will, however warm up pieces
of tofu that are thinly sliced.
If you have a piece of tofu
that's more like this size,
or even like this, I'm going
to show you a little very
simple trick, which is if you're
slicing at an angle, like so,
you're getting these beautiful
pieces that are thin.
It's almost like cutting
a piece of steak.
But if you just angle it.
Similarly, you can
cut anything this way.
But it's beautiful for
tofu, because then you're
going to expose more
surface area to the heat.
I do this when I'm
making ban mi sandwiches.
I would never put an
entire piece of tofu
like this in a ban mi.
For the same reason you slice up
your meat for a deli sandwich.
Slice it thinly.
And it'll lay flat
on your bread,
just like it will lay
flat on your noodles.
All right.
So.
You basically have
two pots going--
one for water and one for broth.
And you bring them up to a boil.
Meanwhile, with your noodles I
like to portion my noodles out
first into each bowls.
These are tasting bowls.
So at home you can make
them as large as you want.
And then I finish tasting
my broth one last time.
And be careful with
broth that's boiling.
You put salt in.
When a pot is boiling,
it will overflow.
And you have to clean it up.
I have cleaned that up many,
many times on my stove.
If you've got an
induction, no problem.
You're just wiping
the thing clean.
But think about that.
All right.
So this is the other
kind of tool that I love.
This is a noodle dunker.
Scum skimmer.
Doodle dunker.
Well, you'll see like
noodle soup strainer,
or noodle strainer.
And the thing with
this is that you can--
I'll just show you.
You dunk this in your noodles
in your pot like this.
You can use this
little guy for pastas,
to blanch vegetables,
whatever you want,
because it's never
going to touch.
You can pull it out very, very
quickly into small portions.
And once that I dump
it into my bowl,
I shake my bowl to
distribute the noodles.
And you're dunking.
How long do you dunk for?
It depends on your noodle.
These fresh noodles take
very, very little time.
With the drier ones, if I
were using the wider ones,
I would dunk them a
little bit longer.
And also it depends.
Do you like your
noodle soft, or do you
like them a little bit chewy?
I beg your pardon?
Once that they are--
here.
I'm just going to
pass that along.
Once that they have softened
like this in the strainer,
you can also use
some chopsticks.
And you can just
poke at it and see.
Yeah.
And then you're going
to add your toppings.
So you arrange your
elements for your bowl
flat like I'm doing like so.
Then you've got your onion.
Then you've got your cilantro.
Your green onion.
So you've got this going.
If you like black
pepper, this is the time
to throw some on there.
Meanwhile, while all
this is happening,
you've got your
garnish plate going.
And so we've got
various different herbs.
And Thai basil is not the
only Vietnamese herb for pho.
In fact, purists will say that
this is a foreign vegetable,
because they're like,
that's like for Thai food.
Just like sriracha
is for Thai food.
What's it doing in my pho?
Those are pho diehards.
This adds a wonderful,
wonderful fragrance to pho.
However, you will go very,
very far with regular mint.
It's refreshing.
It grows like a
weed, my friends.
And you can grow it
in a pot very easily.
And it grows year round
in many, many places.
You keep it indoors.
So mint adds a wonderful,
refreshing quality.
So when you're considering
that garnish plate,
Thai basil, mint, chiles,
lime, sriracha, hoisin sauce,
whatever you want.
In terms of the chiles, Fresnos
are wonderful, as well as
serranos.
Sometimes jalapenos
taste like bell peppers.
I know one little
Vietnamese lady,
she brings her own chilies with
her to Vietnamese restaurant
because she just doesn't
like the jalapeno.
So Fresnos are just wonderful.
Got a moderate heat.
Thai chiles.
If you've got a really
tiny Thai chile like this,
cut it on the bias.
Bias just means diagonal.
Or you can also cut if you
want to in halfsied like this.
The reason why you don't
want to cut really, really
tiny, tiny pieces is that once
you put this into your bowl,
it is very, very
difficult to retrieve.
You will lose it.
And you may be sorry.
So have all these
things on a plate.
If you're into beansprout,
have those two.
You can blanch your
beansprout ahead
of time using this tool
in your pot of water
before you do your noodles,
because your noodles
will cloud up the broth.
And you don't want
your beansprouts
to get a noodle starch bath.
So take all of that
into consideration.
So the last thing you would do--
and you've got your garnishes
sitting out there-- your herbs,
your chili sauces and stuff--
you don't have to
have all these things.
There is no right or wrong
reason or wrong way to eat pho.
OK?
And in fact, when
I grew up, there
was no hoisin sauce or
sriracha, because my parents--
they're hard core.
And so all I got was mint
picked from the yard.
And so there are
many different ways.
And there's actually
a recipe in the book
and on the recipe
cards around that
is for a chili sauce that's
modeled on something sold only
in Vietnam these days.
And it's a really great
fun little sauce to make.
So the last thing you want to do
when the bowl's being assembled
is step up to your
boiling pot of broth,
and then ladle it over.
And when you ladle,
ladle in a circular path.
Why circular?
Because then it will
warm everything up.
All the toppings will
then be warmed if you're
doing a circular motion.
And use a ladle that is
appropriate for the size
of your bowls and stuff.
And then you're through.
And you run to
the table and eat.
And when you're eating pho, I
like to wiggle my noodles up,
because they get really
compacted at the bottom.
So that's what we're going
to do today for you here
at the Google kitchen.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
Thank you so much.
While we're waiting
for tasty treats,
does anybody have questions?
Do you toast your
spices, was the question.
ANDREA NGUYEN: I used to.
I used to be a spice toaster.
And so the idea
there is that you're
helping the oils, the aromatics,
to release their potency.
Well, if you're
going to be simmering
that broth for
four to five hours
or using a pressure cooker--
no.
If you're simmering it
for four to five hours,
I do not toast them,
because they're
going to be-- it's like a
long steep in that hot water.
In the pressure cooker, or
when I make a quick broth using
canned stock, I
do toast it, just
because I'm working faster.
So I want to really
bring up those flavors.
And so I'm going to give
it that little bit of heat.
SPEAKER: Is it OK to
boil your finished broth?
ANDREA NGUYEN: Yes.
It is not OK to boil
your simmering broth.
Reason being is that
if you're boiling--
let's say I've got my
beef bones and my chicken
bones in the pot.
And it's going
really, really harsh,
what happens is
you're going to be
blending all of those
impurities in with the broth.
And that's where you
get the cloudiness.
You're getting rid of
a lot of the cloudiness
through that parboiling
business that I
discussed at the front end,
and also with straining
through the fabric.
And that will get you super,
super crystal clear broth,
I guarantee you.
But that boiling will
suspend stuff in there
if you're not clear.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREA NGUYEN: You
could totally boil that,
because you've strained it.
All the impurities are gone.
It's OK.
I know.
It's confusing.
Yes.
SPEAKER: Is there any way
to decloud cloudy broth?
AUDIENCE: Milk.
ANDREA NGUYEN: Really?
SPEAKER: Olivia says milk.
The milk will bond with the
cloudiness and make it float.
And then what you strain--
oh!
Food lab.
Sure.
Kenji.
He would know.
ANDREA NGUYEN:
Sometimes that works.
Sometimes it doesn't.
SPEAKER: Noted.
ANDREA NGUYEN: And for
example, we actually today--
you can try straining it
again through a coffee filter.
You can try egg
whites, which will--
but you know what?
It's not going to--
it's a look thing
more than anything.
SPEAKER: You should
just eat it, ultimately.
ANDREA NGUYEN: You know what?
If it's like dishwater--
sometimes I'm gonna
tell you this.
I'll tell you this.
I go to some of
these pho shops--
even my favorite pho shops.
And sometimes at
the end of service
when they're maybe at
the bottom of the pot,
the broth is cloudy.
And sometimes too when
you stir up your noodles,
the starches in the noodles will
make the broth a little cloudy.
So that cloudiness is not
necessarily a bad thing.
But sometimes when your
finished broth, if it's cloudy,
you know what?
You just move on and
you make another pot.
I mean, it's just from--
SPEAKER: That's a
great philosophy.
We don't take ourselves
too seriously here.
ANDREA NGUYEN: I don't either.
Yes.
SPEAKER: What's your favorite
pho spot in the Bay Area?
ANDREA NGUYEN: I like this
place down in South San Jose.
So sort of in the hood.
And it's called Pho Y.
Just like the letter y.
Number 1.
SPEAKER: That's how you know
it's going to be a legit place.
There's a number in the name.
ANDREA NGUYEN: All
they serve is pho.
No rice paper rolls.
No rice plates.
You just get chicken or beef.
And the beef is
much, much better.
It's on East Capital Expressway,
close to the first intersection
as you're going
towards the mountains.
And it's like a
moderate sized bowl.
And you go there on the
weekends around 11:30.
And everybody is there.
And it's multicultural.
It's families.
They're kind of rude.
SPEAKER: Again, so legit.
ANDREA NGUYEN: It's so genuine
and honest in the experience.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
ANDREA NGUYEN: As
everybody's getting pho,
I want to give a big thanks to
our staff here at Kitchen Sync.
They take such good care of us.
Any last questions?
There'll be book signing
after we get a chance to eat.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How did you prepare the tofu?
SPEAKER: How did you
prepare that tofu?
ANDREA NGUYEN: Well, the way
that I prepare tofu in the book
is very simple.
So I get a block
of extra-firm tofu.
So that's the tofu that is
sold in a tub with water--
with a moat of water around it.
And so I'll slice the tofu.
The tofu that Google
gets is restaurant size.
So it's a little bit
different than what we see.
But I get the tofu.
And I'll cut it into
pieces about this size.
And then I put it into
a nonstick skillet
with a little bit of soy sauce.
In the book, the recipe
is called pan-seared tofu.
And it's one of my favorite ways
of making a grab and go tofu.
So you put your tofu in there.
No need to do that draining
business, all righty?
Because in the skillet it
will release its liquid.
Add soy sauce, turn
the tofu a few times.
And then you turn on your
heat to around medium or so.
The tofu then will release
its natural liquid.
So it's draining
right there for you.
It's then going to
get coated and pick up
some flavor from the soy sauce.
And then once that the
tofu looks kind of dryish,
add a little bit of oil.
And then you're going to
let that outer coating kind
of sear and fry a little bit.
And then once that's done--
and total cooking time is like
10 minutes-- you are home.
And then you just cool it.
And I keep that in the fridge.
And it lasts for days.
And I use it for pho.
I use it for fried rice.
I'll put it in sandwiches.
I sometimes just eat it
when I'm feeling hangry.
So it's like one of my favorite
tofu convenience foods.
SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for being with us.
ANDREA NGUYEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]